This video was a collaboration between me and Psych2go
Please go check out their channel
They have some really cool videos about
psychology and other topics
What is the most common mental disorder in the United States?
Depression? Bipolar disorder? autism?
It's actually anxiety!
This affects 40 million adults in the U.S.
18 percent of the population
but how this anxiety come about?
The university of Wisconsin-Madison found that anxiety could be inherited
They went further into their studies
using an extended family of rhesus monkeys
to examine which regions of the brain were involved
First, let's go back to 1969 where developmental psychologist
Mary Ainsworth would perform an experiment known as "The strange situation"
in this experiment young children were introduced to
a mildly stressful situation
being left alone with a stranger
Don't worry, the stranger was actually a research assistant
researchers were then able to derive the different temperaments of the children
when they were in that stressful situation
Children either had a secure temperament or an anxious temperament
when pared with a stranger
researchers at the university of Wisconsin-Madison did the same experiment to rhesus monkeys
scanning the brain of about 600 young monkeys
both with and without anxious temperaments
when exposed to a stranger for 30 minutes
They found 3 parts of the brain linked to inherited anxiety
The prefrontal cortex, the limbic system
and the amygdala in the middle of the brain
These areas were shown to have an overactive connection
which in turn links to an increase risk of developing anxiety or depression
Dr. Ned Kalin, senior author of the study explains
What we find as more activity in the anxious brains
is as if the part of the brain that we have evolved to deal with normal threats
have gone super critical responding to mild threats as if they were major
researchers were also able to trace the inheritance of anxiety
discovering 35% of the variations of anxiety can be explained by genetics
while the other percentage is determined by environment
kalin explains: “Basically, we think that to a certain extent, anxiety can provide an evolutionary advantage
because it helps an individual recognize and avoid danger,
but when the circuits are overactive, it becomes a problem and can result in anxiety and depressive disorders"
So what are your thoughts on anxiety?
Do you have anxiety?
Let us know in the comments down below